[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily a
new york judge orders donald trump and
his kids to appear for depositions the
latest in the new york attorney
general's investigation plus one time
doctor accused of murdering dozens of
patients we take a closer look into the
case of william hussill and the movie
theater murder trial will ex-police
captain curtis reeves take the stand in
his own defense but first the sentencing
of kim potter a police officer who's
supposed to serve and protect so much
took so much away from us
she took our baby boy with a single
gunshot through his heart she shattered
mine how long the ex-officer will spend
behind bars for the death of dante
wright long crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin months after she is found guilty
in the death of dante wright
ex-minnesota police officer kim potter
is sentenced to two years in prison per
minnesota sentencing guidelines potter
would serve only 16 months behind bars
and the rest under supervised probation
judge regina chu addressed the shortened
sentence length and got emotional when
reading a statement
i recognize there will be those who
disagree with the sentence
that i granted a significant downward
departure
does not in any way
diminish dante wright's life
his life mattered
officer potter made a mistake
that ended tragically
she never intended to hurt anyone
her conduct cries out for her sentence
significantly below the guidelines
potter was found guilty of first and
second degree manslaughter last december
in the death of 22 year old dante wright
in april 2021 wright was pulled over for
unregistered vehicle tags officers later
attempted to take him into custody when
they discovered a warrant was out for
his arrest potter shot and killed wright
she maintains she accidentally grabbed
her gun instead of her taser before a
sentence was handed down victim impact
statements were read to the court most
notably an emotional speech given by
wright's mother
your honor i hope the defendant is
listening as i speak loud
and clear today
and yes
i refer to her as defendant because i
will not
give her the respect of calling her by
her name she referred to dante over
and over again as the driver
as if killing him wasn't enough to
dehumanize him
she never once said his name
and for that i'll never be able to
forgive you dante's smile was genuine
and big just like his dreams
you took this
you took his future
what he could have done and it was so
many things
april 11th was the worst day of my life
a police officer who was supposed to
serve and protect so much took so much
away from us
she took our baby boy with a single
gunshot through his heart she shattered
mine
my life and my world will never ever be
the same
kim potter also addressed the court and
wright's family sobbing as she gave an
apology
to the family of dante right
i am so sorry
that i brought the death of your son
father brother
uncle grandson
nephew and the rest of your family
to your home
katie i understand a mother's love and i
am sorry i broke your heart
my heart is broken for all of you
earlier when you said that i didn't look
at you
during the trial
i don't believe i had a right to
i didn't even have a right to be in the
same room with you
i am so sorry
that i hurt you so badly
my heart
is broken and devastated for all of you
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney bernardo violona and terry
austin bernard just 24 months is this
the right sentence and what do you think
of the defense's arguments for a lower
sentence
it's actually not the right sentence but
regardless what the sentence could have
been or would have been nothing will
bring back the life of dante wright and
no sentence would signify the worth of
dante wright i'm disappointed with the
sentence but let me just tell you how do
we get here in regards to the defendant
and the defense's argument to the judge
as we know there are sentencing
guidelines there's nothing that is
mandatory about the sentence in terms of
the arguments that were made the defense
attorney made it a point to say that 65
of the time when it goes to sentencing
women the guidelines are not followed
but aside from that one point that he
made that i was really disappointed by
an offended by is that he made dante
right to be the person that because he
was under the influence of marijuana
because he had an open warrant because
he was driving with a suspended uh
registration figure that he caused this
upon himself and argued to the judge
that those are mitigating factors and
why former police officer kim potter
should be sentenced to probation i'm
insulted by that but hey yeah now terry
whose victim impact statement do you
think affected the judge's decision the
most
absolutely none of those statements
affected the judge i believe she had her
mind made up before she walked into that
courtroom you could tell obviously she
was reading from a prepared statement
what i will say is she was persuaded by
the briefs and she looked at the state's
brief and basically said you have not
proven any aggravating circumstances so
that she could exceed the guidelines she
said that the defendant did not cause
greater damage or danger to others and
that kim didn't abuse her authority
obviously i think others would disagree
with that and she listened to the
defense argument she said it was a sad
case and she leaned on the side of kim
potter so definitely she was favoring
the defense there yeah one thing got to
be interested in she looked at a lot of
letters that were sent to her i would
hope that those would make it into the
court file so maybe publicly we can see
what letter she relied on in coming to
this sentence because it was so
significantly lower thank you both still
ahead on law and crime daily william
hussell is set to stand trial next week
everything you need to know ahead of the
opening statements but first the defense
calls its first witness in the murder
trial of ex-cop curtis reeves our legal
analysts break down the case so far
after this
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury bonds
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
defense began calling witnesses friday
morning in the florida case of retired
police captain curtis reeves reeve is on
trial for killing fellow moviegoer chad
olson inside a theater in 2014. reeven
olsen got into an argument over olson
being on his cell phone during movie
previews some witnesses testified to
olson throwing popcorn before the
shooting reef says olson threw his cell
phone at him saying he shot olson in
self-defense testimony began friday with
a detective from the pasco county
sheriff's office he was asked about his
interview tactics after the shooting
happened including why he didn't use
recorders when interviewing witnesses he
was also asked about his experience with
investigating homicides as a defense
attorney questioned his lack of time
spent training in that division the
topic of questioning once again turned
to the cell phone and talk of whether it
had reeves's dna on it
you had a conversation did you not with
the crime scene forensic tech whatever
you want to call it
concerning that phone that was on the
ground
you had a conversation because she asked
you
hey what do you want me to do with this
phone
hey what do you want me to do with this
phone you want me to turn off she picked
up that phone from the floor
with gloves on yes
and started manipulating the phone
to turn it off
there you have to manipulate the buttons
on the phone to get it to turn off yes
because you didn't
know that that phone was possibly used
to strike mr reeves in the head um i was
not aware that that had
that accusation been made because you
know if someone is manipulating a phone
that possibly the dna that is so
critical in a case
may go away on your glove
it's possible it could get wiped off
reeves son and daughter took the stand
friday afternoon we'll hear from them
next on the next episode of law and
crime daily let's bring back criminal
defense attorney bernardo villalona and
terry austin to discuss the defense of
curtis reeves terry what did you think
of the defense's opening witnesses did
they start off strong and is there any
reasonable doubt yet well i think they
had a decent start i will say this
defense attorney attacks everyone he has
a certain style about himself and it
makes you wonder does he believe anybody
anytime it's just antics but i think
having detective aaron smith on the
stand and talking about the tactics is
something that we see done a lot by
defense attorneys they try to say the
investigation wasn't done well and
perhaps it wasn't but this whole phone
incident i think is a red flag really it
really didn't matter whether or not the
dna was on the phone because we know
that the phone belonged to olson and we
know that the phone was in his hand so i
think he's making a big deal about an
issue that really isn't an issue we also
know who the person was who shot so i
think basically uh
you know that it was just a a red
herring there yeah he's trying to make
something out of it i'm not sure how
much he will win on that one bernardo do
you think reeves will take the stand and
if so what do you expect him to say
at this point i don't think there'll be
a need for curtis reeves to take the
stand usually you know when you're
trying self-defense cases you have to
put your client on the stand to be able
to explain to the jury what was going
through their mind for them to believe
that there was a need to use deadly
force however in this case the
prosecution put in mr reeves testimony
not testimony his statements his
omissions to the police so there's
nothing more that he could add in the
sense that i think will help him out in
this case but who knows we'll see what
happens yeah and if they don't if he
doesn't take the stand he doesn't get
cross-examined so maybe that statement
through the interrogation is the best
one he's got i agree with you i hope we
see him understand but might not happen
well coming up on law and crime daily
possible depositions ahead for former
president donald trump and two of his
adult children plus a one-time doctor
accused of murdering dozens of patients
what you need to know in the case of
william husell
next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily was
he committing murder or just doing his
job that's what an ohio jury will have
to decide in the upcoming trial of
william hussell a doctor accused of
killing patients after administering
excessive amounts of painkillers we
spoke a husel's attorney a lawyer who
has worked on some high profile cases in
his career and he says he's not going
down without a fight here's law on crime
sierra gillespie with more
if this prosecution team wants to
convict dr william hussel they're in for
the fight of their life attorney jose
baez is representing intensive care unit
dr william hussell as he faces trial for
the murders of more than a dozen people
who are being treated in the icu the
deaths occurred between september 2014
and november 2018. at mount carmel west
and mount carmel st anne's hospitals in
columbus ohio over two and a half years
35 patients under husel's care died
prosecutors say the vast majority were
given excessive amounts of fentanyl a
synthetic opioid which is stronger than
morphine
detectives reviewed approximately 30 000
pages of documents
consulted with medical professionals and
conducted numerous interviews with
witnesses and family members of the
deceased
the investigation revealed probable
cause linking 25 deaths that were a
direct result of the known therapeutic
doses of drugs including fentanyl
that dr william scott yusul ordered to
be administered in excess of medical
standards
in 2019 a grand jury indicted the 46
year old with 25 counts of murder in
january prosecutors dropped 11 of those
counts establishing a threshold of how
much fentanyl was given hughsol's
defense argued he was doing his job
providing comfort care to patients who
were in pain at the end of their lives
there's something that needs to be known
there's no there was no policy
precluding these doses number one so the
hospital had no limits on
on what dr houston could prescribe and
he prescribed what he felt was in the
best interest of the patient and their
families baez was launched into the
spotlight after a florida jury acquitted
his former client a name you may
recognize casey anthony
it's not unusual for doctors to lose
patients that's just part of being a
doctor but the families of husel's
patients thought there was something
more going on in october 2018 the formal
reports of concern started coming in by
november the death of melissa penx is
believed to have prompted the hospital
to start investigating husel
then by early december heusel was fired
along with at least 20 nurses and other
hospital personnel who were placed on
administrative leave pending the
investigation
june 5th 2019 franklin county prosecutor
at the time ron o'brien announced husel
would be charged with 25 counts of
murder that same day the former doctor
surrendered to columbus police and just
two days later he made bail a judge set
husel's trial date to start in may
2020.the then the coveted 19 pandemic
hit prompting several delays william
hussell will now finally face a jury it
is our sincere hope the families of
these victims will find solace by the
state of ohio
holding dr yusel accountable for his
devious conduct for law on crime daily
i'm sierra gillespie
if convicted each of the 14 counts of
murder who cell is charged with carries
a mandatory sentence of 15 years to life
in prison opening statements are set to
begin on tuesday criminal defense
attorney bernardo violona and co-host
terry austin are back to break down the
trial of william hussell terry what
would you say to the argument that this
is a civil matter and not a criminal one
well you know brian i think it's civil
and criminal obviously it's right for
criminal charges he's being charged
we'll see if there's enough evidence to
say that he was intentionally killing
people but an argument really can be
made and there are civil charges already
brought that he was negligent or
reckless and that the hospital should be
responsible and paying for this and that
he should have some compensatory damages
charged against him because the victims
families suffered as far as this was
concerned but you know we've seen some
of the nurses actually in that civil
case testify that this comfort care near
the end of life is something that you
commonly see and i know for a fact it
happened with my mother when she was
passing so i think for a fact that you
know there are two arguments to this and
you have to determine based on the
evidence whether or not he's liable yeah
but speaking of different arguments i'm
kind of looking at this from a defense
standpoint do you believe the defense
can win based on a missing element of a
crime or a jury who simply believes the
doctor was being compassionate to his
clients
this is going to be a difficult case
because number one you're dealing with
12 jurors so you're going to have to get
a unanimous decision regardless of what
the verdict's going to be so even if you
try to go for jury nullification meaning
that the prosecution proved that case
beyond a reasonable doubt but you want
as a defense attorney for the jury to
set that aside and for other reasons
whether it's compassion or feeling bad
or feeling bad even for those that
passed away because they were coming to
their end and he was just trying to
provide comfort and say you know what
you're not guilty but you need 12 jurors
to be able to reach that conclusion it's
going to be a difficult case i'm not
sure what the defense is going to go
with here but they are strengthened
numbers and you're talking about all
these people that died in your hands
yeah i mean patients not clients
obviously i'm a lawyer not a doctor but
when we come back the latest in the new
york attorney general investigation into
the finances of former president donald
trump will trump and his adult children
face depositions the latest after the
break
[Music]
welcome back now looking at news out of
new york a judge has ordered former
president donald trump don jr and ivanka
to answer questions under oath about the
trump organization's business practices
all three have been subpoenaed by new
york attorney general leticia james she
says it's an effort to uncover the truth
about the company's finances the trumps
have fought back claiming james is
politically motivated but new york
county supreme court justice arthur
engron ordered for the three to be
deposed within the next three weeks as
well as submit any documents that have
been subpoenaed james is inquiring about
several statements of financial
conditions which have been inflated by
millions of dollars the trumps would be
able to plead the fifth so far they have
denied having information affirming the
allegations
what are the judges rule they'll be
deposed but as i said even if they do
testify they'll likely take the plea the
fifth so where do we go from there
well that's the first step that the ag
wants to do is that they want to get at
least the trumps on record saying that
they're going to plead the fifth or they
have nothing to say they want to get an
answer from them so that's the first
step but how do we build a case how is
the aeg going to be able to build a case
and don't forget that they are still a
case in new york county not directly
having to deal with donald trump but
something having to deal with his
organization regardless i'm hoping that
at least at the conclusion of this even
if there are no charges that the ag
releases a report just like how she did
for fullmark governor andrew cuomo yeah
we saw a lot in that as you're saying
the andrew cuomo okay so that's part of
my question with terry if the family is
the pose will the public get to see it
or will this be sealed for years
well you know there's a great argument
that the public should be able to see it
we need transparency here and all of
these individuals are private sentence
citizens there's no reason that it
shouldn't be public he's not claiming
executive privilege we know that he's
got to testify there is a probe of his
business practices and
there is a real good argument that we
should be able to not only listen to
what they have to say but see all of
these documents the accountants released
all of these records decades worth of
records about his finances trump has
said in the past that he knows all about
his finances that he can talk about his
finances so we're hoping that that is
public we can see it we can learn that
information and frankly if he does and
ivana and donald if they all plead the
fifth then we'll know in a civil case
that can be used against them unlike in
a criminal case where it can't right
either there's where there's smoke
there's fire or this is a witch hunt
either way uh accountability and some uh
be able to see these records will help
well thank you for joining us here at
law on crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you